hello everyone and welcome to the last
day of the air things master
preliminaries in a wonderful
uh with a wonderful game between yanni
pomeshi and daniel dubo now now
usually when there's a tournament going
on first i wait then i see which games
are interesting and then i decide which
games to show
and only then do i make my interface
here that you guys can see now but
in the case of nipple playing against
dubo i make the interface up front
because i know it's going to be an
awesome game and this game is uh well
no different it's really really an uh
outstanding one
so uh without further ado let's check
out what happened in this game so enable
with the white pieces
opens with d4 uh sorry about that
uh we have knight to f6 by dubois uh and
c4 now we have g6 knight to c3 and
bishop to g7 we have the king's indian
defense
uh e4 advancing the pawn in the center
and the d6 now we have bishop to e2
and now do both castles and now there
are uh plenty of options here
knight to f3 bishop to g5 being the most
popular ones uh
uh nipple goes for a bit
less played one but it's also uh there
are over like a thousand games in the
database only
the other options are much more popular
so here knight to c6 both of them just
continued development
d5 not waiting for e5 so the knight can
be shifted to e7 but rather d5 forcing
the knights to e5
knights to e5 and now the immediate f4
so
the knight is under attack knight e to
g4 and now bishop to d2 of course not
allowing the capture here and now
knight back to h6 and already you can
see uh it's quite
quite an unusual knight set up here so
nepo immediately goes h3 takes away the
g4 square from black's pieces and then
now comes e6
challenging this pawn here and now there
is one game in the database where g4 was
played or rather even more games but the
move
nipple plays uh we have uh d captures on
e6 is a new move
so already as of movie 11 uh we have a
completely new game so here
bishop captures on e6 and now nipple
goes to g4
and now the threat is g5 just attacking
both of the knights and winning them but
duba advances his rook to e8 he doesn't
care about g5 because
g5 here would be a bit too soon for
example knight captures on e4
you grab a piece and then you get
checkmated queen h4 check king has only
one square king of one and queen to f2
checkmate
so of course uh you're not gonna allow
that so after this rook to e8 move
uh we have knight to f3 uh and now
bishop back to d7 opening up uh the
the rook's e file and here asking white
or rather daring white to go
g5 here and after some consideration
this is exactly what dubois did he
played g5
attacked both of the knights and now uh
uh sorry nipple attacked both of the
knights and duval captured on e4 so
knight captures an e4
uh g captures on h6 accepting the
sacrifice and now
bishop captures on h6 we have knight
captures on e4
rook captures an e4 and now after some
uh three minutes of think uh
we have f5 by nipple and now uh the
position is very very intense what you
play here uh there's this uh
tension here between the two bishops uh
but dubo is down a piece so he has to
take that into consideration he can to
just trade all
everything and then uh hope to hope to
still be able to check mate nipple's
king
and uh here a lot of things are possible
for example if you just go for the trade
bishop captures queen captures then you
already allow
whites to just castle the safety uh and
if queen to e7
going after the bishop here you can just
play king f2 make room for the rook on
a1 and even after rook to e8 you can
seem to play bishop to d3
and even though black has queen and two
rooks on the e file there is no real way
uh to take advantage of them so here
after considering
for some six minutes maybe even longer
uh we have queen to f8 uh by do both
so now the bishop is defended and also
maybe you can shift the queen over to g7
in the future maybe put some pressure
along the side of this diagonal
uh all depending on what white plays and
here nepo immediately castled after
queen to effect was played
meaning that he was expecting such a
move so rook eight to e8
uh do both doubles up on the e file and
now bishop to d3
challenging the rook here and now you'd
think a move like
bishop to e3 check would happen where
maybe bishops would be traded real
captures would happen
nope duval continues in great style he
plays rook to e3 he blocks uh
the attack on his own bishop and he
offers a rook on e3
uh nepo accepts the rook with bishop
captures bishop captures witchcraft king
to jitu and now bishop to c6 and now
double the bishop pair
uh is fully operational as you can see
here so it's not going to be easy nipple
still up a piece
but uh i mean this is uh quite quite a
position to hold so here queen to e1
putting the queen in front of the rook
but all of white's pieces are on
are on white light squares so not
not all that many discoveries you can do
with this bishop so here
we have g5 by dubaf we already mentioned
queen to g7 is a possibility you could
put some pressure here
as nothing is defending the b2 pawn uh
but dubois
prefers this g5 move now he wants to
shift the bishop over to f4 it will be
nicely defended and the e
file will belong to black's rook so here
queen to g3 getting the queen out of the
way and now bishop to f4
attacking the queen we have queen to g4
getting out of harm's way and
now again you have to be very careful it
moves like uh
well f6 are coming which will open up
this uh
diagonal for the light square bishop so
immediately rook to e3
now puts uh more pressure on the f3
knight but also puts pressure on the
bishop here so nepo defends it
rook to d1 and now comes queen to g7
uh queen to g7 uh you kind of want to
get the queen into the game the queen on
f8 isn't all that impressive
uh but what black should definitely
consider is this f6 move and then
maybe you can bring the queen into the
game later on double up here on the e
file
uh point is you don't want to uh you
know allow this
bishop on d3 to come alive if you allow
white to play f6 then this could be a
huge
problem so here uh dubois decided to go
a queen to g7
instead and now comes rook to f3 again
f6
is definitely an option here you can
always play this because uh
simply because you don't want black to
play f6 so you might want to even give
up a
uh to open up this bishop but uh nipple
not in a hurry he plays
rook to f2 first and now comes queen to
eight shade by duboff
here dubo is being very greedy he wants
to play h5 here
and attack white's queen or rather trap
wise queen
but it's easier said than done because
f6 was
still a better option here here nipple
just plays queen to h5 he prevents this
h5 push
and now the queen doesn't really have
all that much to do by playing f2 nip
also defends the b2 pawn so there's no
queen captures and b2 happening
so queen back to g7 by nippo uh uh
sorry by dubois and now uh f6 again is
an option here but first
king to f1 nipple on pins here he
doesn't want uh
uh to constantly be pressured by this uh
bishop spin so now the knight can move
and here
the problem for dubo is that uh his
position has worsened a little bit but
he's
very low on the clock uh nipple is some
over five minutes on the clock whereas
dubo is uh 30 seconds on the clock but
okay you still get a
10 seconds uh increment per move so here
bishop to g3
attacking the rook on f2 but now only
now
uh nepo goes for it f6 attacking the
queen so
not much you can do here you have to
capture the pawn
so queen captures an f6 and now not
queen captures an h7 even though you
could play this but it's
uh if you go for queen captures on h7
then it's king of f8 and
now you're you're lost uh i mean maybe
you could capture with the bishop but
after capturing with the queen now
you're just in a terrible position like
this is hanging this is hanging and not
much you can do here
even if you trade queens for example
captures and captures now you're going
to play bishop captures on f3
and bla white is uh white is lost here
even if you try something like this
let's say you captured the rook captures
and now rook to f3 check
everything gets traded off you're still
in a king and rook end game but black is
up two pawns so
this is sufficient for for a win so
instead after
queen captures an f6 not a queen
captures an h7 but rather queen captures
and g5 with check nipple forces a queen
trade
doop of trades we have captures captures
in the now h6
now attacking that knight but nepo finds
the absolute best move
and this is probably the move that uh
dubo missed otherwise
uh he might not have even gone into all
of this
but it's knight captures on f7 and now
there's a problem
because even if you remove the defender
of the knight it's not a problem
because knight captures h6 pawn with
check and you cannot go to h7 you can
only go to g7
and now it's knight f5 check and you
pick up the rook here king moves
knight captures rook bishop captures and
it's a rook and bishop against two
bishops
uh same amount of pawns of course white
will win this
so after knight captures on f7 duvel had
to play king to g7 but
this is more than enough for nipple
knight to d8 he moves the knight out of
the way
bishop captures an f2 king captures and
now even
rook to f3 check but it doesn't help we
have
king to e2 and now rook captures on h3
uh we have rook to f1 now uh
preparing a little trap for dubai but do
extremely low on time and trying to get
back some material
he played rook to h to check king to e3
and now dubo grabbed the pawn here
but now the position is completely lost
even though it seems like there's some
counter play here it there really isn't
so feel free to pause the video and find
the forced checkmate in two uh while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh spotting
the beautiful mate in two and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's
knight the e6 check uh rook to f7 check
will also win you the game but this is
just
instant knights the e6 check and now the
bishop covers these squares the rook
covers these squares these are the only
two squares available for the black king
and once you play the king to either of
those squares it's just
rook to f8 checkmate and that's just it
but after this uh
knight's the e6 check uh it was actually
in this position that
dubo resigned to the game he did not
allow the mate to appear on the board
so a really really exciting game already
from round one
uh or rather round nine but the first
game of day three and like i said i i
prepared the interface before the game
even started because i knew
uh as the two of them were playing it's
gonna be a wild one and i think i uh
mixed up the names uh
during this video quite a few times so
story about that i do that sometimes i
have no idea why
it's not on purpose uh it it just
happened so we're
really sorry about that uh so yeah
that's uh the game i do hope you guys
enjoyed it
really hoping that the two of them play
like a lot of games throughout their
careers because it's just awesome to
watch this
so i do hope you guys enjoyed it as well
uh i would like to thank
william botti jerry gauss angus
and jack neville for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens
in the chess world uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day
and just because we didn't uh check it
out yesterday
uh not that uh here are the standings uh
after yesterday
this these are the standings before uh
today's uh
games so uh i forgot to show it
yesterday it's from just 24. so
let's just check it out uh dublin first
place uh
well share it first with nakamura magnus
cross
then with four points aleksandra grisha
kenya pognishi with three and a half
maksim
uh bashar al-agrav and krishna and with
three points on ishgiri and david
so maksim hare krishna giri and david
anton will have to fight really hard to
get into the top eight in the last
day of the preliminaries so uh once
again thank y'all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day